no crees
listo como están buenas tardes vamos a
comenzar la sesión de hoy mi nombre es
laura camacho
y hoy vamos a platicar un poquito sobre
el programa de capacitación con que
estamos teniendo con ustedes cuáles son
los requisitos con los que ustedes
tienen que cumplir hasta el momento para
poder tener reconocimiento sobre su
esfuerzo y el tiempo que han invertido
en la capacitación y bueno repasar un
poquito cuáles son los tres módulos
cuestiones básicas para todos aquellos
que apenas se unen y que van a empezar a
utilizar khan academy
y que no han creado clases o no están
participando en el campeonato entonces
es bueno ver comencemos
este es el programa de capacitación
voy a ser un poco más grande son tres
módulos
entonces en estos tres módulos tenemos
el módulo 1 que empezó en agosto que
cubrió todo lo referente a los primeros
pasos en khan academy el plan de acción
para 2018 2019 y la implementación de
las mejores prácticas los lineamientos
generales del programa de capacitación y
para conocer la plataforma evidentemente
y las nuevas características y un
detalle peculiar y muy importante de la
mentalidad de crecimiento las
actividades de mentalidad de crecimiento
que se integran al contenido de khan
academy en el módulo 2 que corrió entre
agosto y septiembre se cubrió lo
referente al campeonato que es y cómo
comenzar el campeonato recordemos que
comenzó el 10 de septiembre y tiene una
duración de 10 semanas todavía nos
quedan cinco semanas más podemos
participar en el campeonato no pasa nada
nunca es tarde
también se cubrió la parte de cómo
motivar a los alumnos durante el
campeonato reconocer sus logros cómo
reconocer sus logros y lo que se debe
hacer para ser reconocido como un
maestro campeón como entrenar a otros y
bueno asignar tareas
nuevamente repasa un poquito las
características de la plataforma para
fomentar la mentalidad de crecimiento y
bueno el resumen del vídeo del módulo 1
ok para todos aquellos que no pudieron
participar de igual manera esta sesión
pues queda grabada y pueden ver esta
sesión y las pasadas para que puedan
ponerse al corriente en lo que se está
haciendo esta sesión del día de hoy ya
es parte del módulo 3 que ocurre de
octubre a diciembre y entonces vamos a
ver cómo motivar a los alumnos cómo
crear ceremonias para reconocer los
logros y los esfuerzos todo lo referente
a la preparación del examen y obviamente
el reconocimiento para ustedes maestros
por su labor y por el tiempo invertido
en la capacitación sale entonces bueno
cuáles son los requerimientos para
obtener el primer certificado es el
certificado del módulo 1 bueno pues a
haber participado en el webinar de
agosto
y crear una clase asignar contenido y
completar las tareas asignadas
si ustedes no partizán no participaron
perdón en este webinar de agosto les
repito no pasa nada pueden regresar y
verlo en el canal de khan academy
español en youtube para que puedan
ponerse al tanto
ahora el reconocimiento para su esfuerzo
se les van a proveer reconocimientos no
certificados reconocimientos por sus
horas de capacitación por el tiempo que
están invirtiendo en esto por unirse a
la comunidad de docentes innovadores y
obviamente recibir el apoyo de
especialistas del equipo de khan academy
en mexico
algo bien importante para el registro de
esta capacitación si es que alguien no
lo ha hecho tienen que llenar un
formulario con el corredor de khan
academy o sea con el correo que están
utilizando para khan academy que es
arroba el dominio de su escuela que
evidentemente pues en este caso sería
con la ley por ejemplo para poder
recibir el reconocimiento no sus correos
personales por favor
esa liga del registro yo creo que
christine si me ayudas la podríamos
compartir en el chat para que ustedes
puedan acceder a ella si es que hay
alguien que no se ha registrado todavía
sale también tenemos una liga con que es
un documento perdón con información del
programa en donde a lo largo de todo
este programa de capacitación se les va
a estar actualizando con información
relevante sobre la capacitación
si alguien tiene dudas o no sabe cómo
crear una cuenta ahorita lo vamos a ver
tenemos que entrar a ese punto
khan academy punto org o hereje si
alguien tiene también por ahí de los
nuestros usuarios ya registrados y que
estén participando con carne academy si
alguien tiene problemas con soporte
técnico o alguna situación en especial
por ejemplo que sus alumnos no puedan
ver las actividades pasadas que siempre
se pueden volver a publicar o que algún
alumno no se por equis razón no pueda
completar una actividad o yo no pueda
asignar el contenido o lo que sea hay
una página de soporte y de todas formas
si ustedes tuvieran alguna duda o una
pregunta siempre está el correo
electrónico el que pueden contactarnos
que es o la arroba khan academy punto o
hereje vale
entonces aquí tenemos la liga de
registro
la liga del programa y vamos a ver un
poquito una demo en vivo para que puedan
ustedes
repasaron familiarizarse con el registro
en khan academy
el registro cuando tenemos que traer la
página en ese punto khan academy punto o
hereje por favor cuando ustedes entren a
la página y quieran hacer el registro en
el link de regístrate tienen tres
opciones podemos registrarnos con
nuestra cuenta de correo electrónico que
es lo que les sugerimos con su cuenta de
google si ustedes tienen por ahí una
cuenta de gmail o con la cuenta de
facebook les pedimos por favor que no se
registren con la cuenta de facebook ya
que a veces cambiamos de cuenta de
facebook o no nos no nos acordamos del
password o ya no la utilizamos o lo que
sea entonces lo recomendable por favor
es que puedan ustedes entrar con
registrarse con su cuenta del colegio
sale con su cuenta de correo electrónico
una vez que ya hicimos el registro que
entramos aquí a khan academy a ustedes
les aparecerá esta misma pantalla que a
mí y entonces tenemos aquí la
oportunidad de agregar una clase de
crear una clase cuando yo creo una clase
ahorita de momento no nos aparece este
banner de que ya empezó el campeonato
que es lo que les decía que es
vaya esta dinámica o concurso con sus
propios alumnos sus propios grupos que
empezó el 10 de septiembre pero bueno le
damos clic en agregar una clase y tengo
que introducir un nombre para esta clase
entonces puede ser el nombre que yo
quiera por ejemplo física 2 matemáticas
3 grupo avanzado grupo básico
matemáticas el que ustedes quieran los
supercampeones o como ustedes quieren
puedo hacerlo de esta manera o puedo
importar mi clase desde google classroom
si ustedes tienen ya una cuenta d
dominio en gmail y quieren ustedes
conectar su google chrome si lo están
usando con khan academy se puede hacer
basta con que yo dé clic en conectar con
una clase de google chrome en este caso
de esta cuenta que yo estoy empleando yo
no tengo google clase conectado pero
bastaría con darle clic
en mi cuenta entrar a google gerson y
seleccionar la clase que quiero que esté
relacionada con esta clase de khan
academy para que me importen todos esos
datos si me importan los alumnos y puede
estar trabajando en sincronía sale en
este caso me voy a regresar acá voy a
crear una clase de grupo básico de
matemáticas algo bien importante es que
utilizar khan academy no es exclusivo ya
de matemáticas y ciencias tenemos por
ahí profesores de historia de tecnología
de economía que utilizan khan academy
porque ya hay contenido del canaka de mí
para estas materias específicamente
historia por ejemplo no
historia pero las actividades de
mentalidad de crecimiento son super
interesantes
entonces ese contenido que es nuevo nos
ayuda a seguir desarrollando la
inteligencia de nuestros alumnos porque
pues al final de cuentas el cerebro es
un músculo que se tiene que ejercitar
entonces ya puse el nombre de mi clase
doy clic en siguiente
y aquí es donde yo escojo el contenido
que yo voy a estar trabajando si yo
quiero trabajar matemáticas pues yo
puedo escoger el contenido aquí por
ejemplo quiero matemáticas elementales y
quiero no sé
geometría básica pero también quiero el
contenido de matemáticas por grado el
contenido a lo mejor de primero de
secundaria sale aquí tenemos contenido
de ciencias como les decía yo he
contenido ya de economía y finanzas de
computación esto de mentalidad de
crecimiento ojo para el campeonato las
actividades de mentalidad de crecimiento
nos dan más puntos
entonces si ustedes están participando
en campeonato pero no han digamos qué
agregado el contenido de mentalidad de
crecimiento sus clases háganlo por favor
ahorita les explico cómo lo podemos
hacer cuando la clase ya está creada
pero si le estamos creando desde cero
entonces aquí escogemos el contenido de
mentalidad de crecimiento y le damos
clic en siguiente se nos genera un
código de esta clase entonces este
código nosotros podemos
proporcionárselos a los alumnos para que
ellos puedan entrar ellos tendrán que
entrar aquí a khan academy punto o
hereje diagonal join y teclear este
código sale incluso tenemos
de imprimir las instrucciones para
pasárselas a los chicos y que puedan
ellos
entrar sale se los imprimimos es este
cuadrito se los damos con el código de
la clase
y listo ok o bien nuevamente podemos
agregar a los alumnos en estos métodos
por ejemplo si importamos la clase de
clase
automáticamente vamos a estar trabajando
en sincronía podemos enviar una
invitación por correo electrónico pero
ustedes
evidentemente manualmente tendrán que ir
metiendo las direcciones de los chicos o
si sus alumnos son menores de 13 años
entonces crear una que ustedes pueden
crear una cuenta de khan academy para
ellos sale en este caso pues yo decido
pasarles digamos el código a mis alumnos
doy clic en siguiente y listo mi clase
ya está creada vale entonces ya voy a
poder ver aquí los ejercicios los vídeos
los artículos para la clase asignárselos
a los estudiantes y ver la clase la
página de la clase para dar seguimiento
al avance de estos alumnos
ya le doy clic en entendido
y ahora sí ya estoy en esta clase que se
llama grupo básico de matemáticas dice
varios cursos porque obviamente tengo el
contenido de varias materias aunque es
de matemáticas por ejemplo en lo que yo
seleccioné pues recordemos que tengo
geometría básica tengo el contenido de
matemáticas elementales de lo que
corresponde a primero secundaria y la el
contenido de mentalidad de crecimiento
sale en el caso de ustedes profes que ya
tengan creadas las clases y que quieran
agregar el contenido de mentalidad de
crecimiento porque no lo tienen o porque
no lo han agregado cuando entren a sus
clases y le den clic aquí en la materia
digamos sobre el contenido les aparece
la opción de editar cursos entonces ahí
se nos abre este menú para que puedan
ustedes agregar lo de mentalidad de
crecimiento
ahora ya estoy en esta pestaña que se
llama contenido aquí me aparece el
contenido de la materia digamos que yo
seleccione de matemáticas elementales o
de geometría básica vamos a cambiarnos
por ejemplo líneas rectas este es el
tema cada tema tiene subtemas y
lecciones entonces por ejemplo si yo
quisiera asignarles a mis alumnos todo
lo referente a líneas rectas y le diera
clic en este botoncito quiere decir que
les estoy asignando 12 actividades de
líneas rectas para participar en
campeonato es necesario que por lo menos
a la semana les asigne tres actividades
es muy poquito
es absolutamente fácil hacerlo pero
bueno no necesariamente tengo que
asignarles toda la unidad digamos podría
hacerlo de una por una por ejemplo
asignar la de términos y clasificaciones
en geometría y a lo mejor la de repaso
de rectas segmentos de recta
y rayos entonces son dos le puedo darle
clic en el botón asignar me está
diciendo que voy a asignar dos elementos
para mi clase que se llama grupo básico
aquí no tengo estudiantes todavía si
tuviera estudiantes bueno me parecería
aquí la lista y tengo una fecha límite
por ejemplo yo hoy es 9 de octubre y yo
no la quiero para mañana pero les voy a
dar la oportunidad para que la tengan
suficiente tiempo de hacerla hasta el 12
de octubre y puedo incluso también
cambiar la hora vale otra ventaja que
tengo es que bueno la puedo asignar
directamente yo ahorita no puedo asignar
porque no tengo alumnos
ahorita haré otra actividad en una clase
donde si tenga o puedo guardar y asignar
la más tarde y digamos que se me guarda
como un borrador
entonces no pierdo lo que yo ya
intentaba trabajar con mis alumnos o lo
que estaba preparando
vale me voy a cambiar a una clase donde
tenga un alumno por ahí tengo está hoy
y aquí tengo una clase con un alumno
nada más
esperamos a que me cargue
ok por ejemplo aquí están las tareas una
vez que yo asignó tareas
y aquí viene el nombre de mi alumno o de
mi alumna y las actividades que yo he
dejado y lo que va sacando en este caso
por ejemplo esta alumna realmente no ha
participado pero puedo checar el
desempeño por alumno o por tarea
y puedo checar con cierta cierta
periodicidad o sea todo lo que ha hecho
hasta el día de hoy para entregar el día
de hoy para entregar en los últimos
siete días o en los últimos 30 días o
incluso un rango personalizado
también puedo irme a la parte de la
vista de la actividad
aquí no hay ninguna actividad en la
clase pero si tuviéramos ya actividades
asignadas aquí me va a parecer que es lo
que ha estado pasando en mi clase ayer
hoy en los últimos 7 días todo el tiempo
sale para ver cuál es el comportamiento
de mis alumnos
aquí tengo la lista de usuarios de
alumnos que yo tengo registrados y en la
parte de configuración bien importante
aquí yo puedo cambiar el nombre de la
clase pudiera eliminarla y descargar los
datos de los estudiantes en una hoja de
cálculo y también puedo sincronizar con
google clausuró para todos aquellos que
ya tengan esta fue una pregunta que nos
hicieron el día de hoy por la mañana si
yo ya tengo clase pero no no creé mi
clase desde cero haciendo la vinculación
conclusión cómo lo puedo hacer pues muy
fácil entramos a la clase a la
configuración y entonces aquí damos clic
en sincronizar con google chrome y es lo
mismo me va a pedir que escoja de esas
clases que yo tenga ya creadas en caso
cual con cualquier o sincronizar saleh
es un pasito que nos toma medio minuto
y de esta manera todo lo que nosotros
hagamos dentro de khan academy que se va
a ver reflejado dentro de clase
ahora bien importantísimo para
participar en el campeonato
necesitamos tener clases con por lo
menos 10 alumnos ese es el número mínimo
que necesitamos 10 alumnos en una clase
y que todas nuestras clases estén
activas es decir si yo tengo todavía en
mi cuenta por ahí alguna
alguna clase del ciclo escolar pasado o
del semestre pasado en donde esos
alumnos ya no están activos porque yo ya
no les estoy dando clases entonces por
favor vayan entren a esa clase váyanse a
la configuración y denle click en
eliminar por favor de esa forma vamos a
ir depurando las clases que nosotros
vamos a tener aquí en el menú
y vamos a poder participar en el
campeonato con todas las clases que
estén activas vale ahora bien
como bien dice aquí ya empezó el
campeonato empezó el 10 de septiembre
vamos a la mitad nos quedan todavía
cinco semanas más no es tarde para
incorporar incorporarnos perdón al
campeonato y entonces lo que tengo que
hacer es ya que estoy asignándoles las
actividades a mis alumnos puedo darle
clic en este botón que dice revisar mi
avance y entonces ver qué están haciendo
los alumnos
en este caso por ejemplo aquí dice
campeonato completa tres tareas promedio
por estudiante para ir subiendo de nivel
nosotros vamos desbloqueando copas o
desbloqueando niveles entonces
dependiendo del comportamiento de la
actividad que vayan teniendo los alumnos
pues entonces yo voy desbloqueando todos
estos niveles y aquí por ejemplo me dice
cuántos días restan para completar el
nivel 6 me restan 37 días y bueno cuál
es el porcentaje de logro yo puedo ir
revisando aquí el progreso así lo de
clic aquí pues realmente no hay ningún
avance nuevo y lo puedo ir revisando por
clase aquí en este caso pues estoy en la
en la clase de biología de primero se
saleh y aquí es donde nosotros conforme
vayamos desbloqueando copas o subiendo
de niveles también podemos celebrar el
logro de los alumnos
e ir perdón y llevando el registro de lo
que se está haciendo ahora si alguno de
ustedes tiene dudas sobre esto
independientemente de la explicación que
estamos dando bueno cuando ustedes
entran a su plataforma aquí dice aprende
más y también viene un apartado de
mentalidad de crecimiento
vamos a abrir
ok aquí viene digamos todo el programa
de las actividades de mentalidad de
crecimiento que es esto bueno son
ejercicios que están segmentados para
primaria y secundaria y para
bachillerato
que hablan sobre el cerebro como cómo
trabaja nuestro cerebro
como nosotros podemos utilizar los
errores para seguir creciendo seguir
aprendiendo para que sean digamos
escalones en los cuales nosotros pisamos
nuestros errores para seguir mejorando
saleh entonces aquí viene todo el
programa y las actividades de mentalidad
de crecimiento para que ustedes puedan
revisarlas y hacerse una idea de lo que
nosotros estamos trabajando acá
vale no sé si hasta el momento haya
alguna duda en el chat
vamos a ver christina no sé si haya
habido preguntas hasta ahorita o si
quieres que retomemos algo en particular
pues no sé si hay preguntas pero vamos a
ver
hay preguntas estamos viendo y alguien
dijo alta f4 para ganar un nivel ojalá
fuera tan fácil
hay quien está participando en el
campeonato
o
ok
muchas gracias dolores
bien si alguien de ustedes quiere cómo
retomar los webinars y las sesiones que
se han dado los puede encontrar en el
canal de youtube de khan academy español
basta con que entremos a youtube y
tecleamos khan academy español para
encontrar el canal y estos webinars
están disponibles aquí en la lista de
vídeos
para que puedan regresar sobre sus pasos
digamos si es que no nos tomamos el
webinar por ejemplo de agosto bueno pues
lo buscamos o si quiero obtener más
información del campeonato de la
capacitación aquí por ejemplo está la
capacitación del módulo 2
están participando todos todos entienden
cómo inscribirse en el campeonato es qué
quiero saber si han tenido éxito con
esto porque podemos revisar esto también
porque todas las personas que están
participando en el programa de
capacitación también tienen que
participar en el campeonato para recibir
su reconocimiento para módulo 2
entonces podrías hacer esto voy a
compartir la liga anoche para usar para
ver si todos ya
ajá es la liga que les decíamos al
principio o sea que llenaran con su
dirección la dirección de correo
electrónico que usan para khan academy
no para que puedan tener el
reconocimiento y para el programa
devastación y también para inscribirse
en el campeonato esto es un requisito
para el volver 2
tienes que llegar
a esa liga voy a compartirla en el chat
ok perfectísimo si con esa liga
ustedes se inscriben digamos
al campeonato pero
tomando como parte digamos de esta
capacitación entonces
retomo lo que les decía hace un
segundito es importante que dentro de
khan academy ustedes creen las clases y
estas clases tengan 10 alumnos por lo
menos cosa que yo creo que todos los
docentes acá presentes si tenemos
10 alumnos por lo menos y que sean
clases activas que no sean clases ya
viejitas digamos o de ciclos pasados
semestres pasados
saleh y asignemos por lo menos tres
actividades a la semana ojo si tenemos
que asegurarnos para seguir avanzando
dentro del campeonato que todos los
chicos contesten las actividades porque
a lo mejor si estoy cumpliendo con
dejarles yo las tres actividades pero no
todos las están contestando entonces así
no vamos a avanzar es necesario que
ellos cumplan con esas tres actividades
que estamos dejando a la semana
obviamente si dejan más está perfecto
pero el mínimo son tres actividades
saleh
te parece bien así christine quieres qué
tengamos más nos detengamos más en otra
cosa
creo que no hay dudas estoy checando el
chat
y creo que no hay dudas
si hay varios profesores que están
participando en campeonato y nos da
muchísimo gusto algo bien importante
también es que si ustedes están ya
celebrando los logros de sus alumnos
están utilizando khan academy y
participando en el campeonato y ustedes
tienen fotografías videos de cómo
celebran los logros con sus alumnos y
las comparten en redes sociales
entonces utilicen el hashtag campeonato
2018 o en su defecto que nos hagan
llegar a ese material o la arroba khan
academy punto o hereje porque estamos
preparándolo para ustedes en un futuro
con ese material
de las celebraciones con sus alumnos
alguien acá de nuestros asistentes tiene
alguna duda de cómo asignar contenido
cómo crear las clases cómo vincular con
classroom algo de lo que ya hayamos
visto aquí tenemos por ejemplo la
pestaña de estudiantes estoy en vista
del profesor entonces tengo la pestaña
de estudiantes estos son todos los
estudiantes que yo tengo registrados
acá a la pestaña de recursos
algo que quisieran que revisáramos
la vista lo mejor de alumnos
aquí si yo me voy a mi perfil en donde
dice la hora o el nombre de ustedes y se
van a la página del inicio del
aprendizaje van a tener la vista del
alumno por si alguno de ustedes tiene
dudas de bueno ok yo ya sé lo que veo
como profesor pero exactamente cuando yo
les dejé algo a mis alumnos cómo lo van
a ver pues sí me voy aquí a mi perfil y
página de inicio del aprendizaje es
el perfil digamos de del alumno
y entonces aquí tenemos las tareas que
se tienen para entregar en los próximos
siete días sus cursos por ejemplo pues
yo había por ahí asignado la de líneas
rectas en algún momento pues puedo
empezar a trabajar sobre eso
recuerden que la vista del alumno no es
nada más lo que nosotros dejamos sino
que ellos también pueden empezar a
buscar contenido o agregar cursos por su
cuenta para ir ellos progresando
vamos a ver
y dudas por ahí christina de alguien en
el chat
pero ya me la canacar en el que bien
muchísimas gracias por la excelente por
ahí dolores dice en la hoja de excel
salen los alumnos que están trabajando
si dolores cuando tú haces el vaciado de
la hoja de cálculo si es cómo hacer una
copia digamos del avance de tus alumnos
con los nombres y
no voy a regresar acá
[Música]
con los nombres y las actividades
o la dac paranormal
como puedes entrar aquí a khan academy
puedes entrar en la liga a ese punto
khan academy punto o hereje
voy a la configuración y entonces aquí
puedo descargar
la hoja de cálculo
vamos a descargar esta hoja para que
puedas ver
no me está dejando vamos a intentarlo
nuevamente
y acá
me va a abrir la hoja de cálculo
por ahí christine le está dando las
instrucciones a alguien en el chat y es
muy importante que después de escribirse
usando la vida que tienes que hacer clic
en el banner que vas a ver es azul y eso
es cómo pueden inscribirse esto es algo
muy importante no sólo tienen que
inscribirse en en caracas me tiene que
hacer click en el botón azul en el
banner
perfecto respondiendo la pregunta d
dolores esta es la hoja de cálculo que
yo descargue entonces aquí vienen las
actividades por ejemplo que yo dejé el
nombre del estudiante para cada una de
estas actividades la puntuación que
obtuvo
vamos a abrir esta columna y la fecha
límite que tenía para completarlas vale
entonces en este caso este alumno no ha
completado las actividades pero si las
hubiese completado este es el vaciado
que yo obtengo de esa clase porque la
saqué de esta clase de biología en donde
tengo a esta alumna entonces este es el
vaciado que yo puedo descargar
salen
alguna otra duda por ahí
y creo que no
creo que no
no verdad
bueno aquí para apoyarte pueda también
compartir
por ello para el programa en cuestión y
si tiene dudas
excelente
[Aplausos]
[Música]
entonces ya hay cristinos está
compartiendo el chat la dirección si
tienen alguna duda por favor escríbanos
nosotros los podemos apoyar en cualquier
momento para hacer el registro de cómo
crear las clases o asignar contenido y
bueno pues muchísimas gracias a todos
los que están participando de esta
capacitación y en el campeonato
recuerden que si por ahí hay alguien que
no se ha registrado en el formulario que
nos compartió christine por favor
háganlo porque con base en eso es que se
les va a poder dar sus reconocimientos
de participación en el campeonato y en
esta en esta participación digo en esta
capacitación
vale
algo más christina
si no es esto pero muchísimas gracias
por venir y estamos en contacto y mucha
suerte con
al campeonato y también con los 115
muchas gracias a todos por su tiempo nos
vemos muy pronto hay grande